yeah beans are amazing you know after
the
the clint eastwood speech eastwood it
became thank hashtag eastwood it was
just means it means that you can going
it entirely
it means you take a picture of yourself
looking just looking at a chair
and there are there are there are now
pictures of dogs online this was the day
after I mean that's best I think also
means have a half-life of like but
reddit is the place where a lot of that
originates which is interesting it's
like me what's the deal you vote you
vote it up it's this is an upvote down
vote system so anyone who has an account
can either pass today a boat which that
thumbs up or down which is and that's
but how and they aggregate the reaction
and whoever has whatever whatever no
matter what has the most up votes it
goes to the top of their list you think
that you think that's where a lot of the
memes or JT yeah especially cuz you look
at all of these content sites with a
poster all of these websites let's feed
or something
let's feed ton of them also a lot of
them YouTube clips that become that go
viral first get their big first push I'm
gonna some weirdo will post it to unless
it's called subreddit say more specified
topics within reddit so there is like
are you active are you an active render
I look at it every day
I don't contribute and I don't have an
account yeah I just like to observe a
look at must be I do BuzzFeed I do
concur sometimes when I'm feeling okay
particularly shitty about myself cause
interesting because it's it's the most
successful drag slash it is a rag it's a
total rag but at the same time they have
interesting things to say sometimes
there's this large or they'll they'll
promote interesting conversations
sometimes like half of it is you know
who just had tweeted like new plate
tweeters like nudes of themselves yeah
dick pics like and the other side is if
you know silver bike gay rights like you
know like being informing important
political things this is why I hate by
the way this is why I hate getting
coffee into the saucer because every
time you looked it up it drips onto the
paper let's do this see that that that
made it 100 percent where is living okay
no drip but now I know that under that
saucer this and it was a lot of coffee
everywhere